longtime executive in the National
Basketball Association and a senior vice
president for the Orlando Magic joining
us here on draft day thanks for calling
in Pat really appreciate it thanks rich
how much nice nice to catch up with you
absolutely we chatted on the day where
you were a part of the ping-pong ball
situation that went down and you have
the sixth overall selection tonight
how much is your phone been ringing for
teens trying to flip established players
to you to try and get that sixth pick
Pat well rich I would say that our our
new basketball executives are new for
basketball front office have have walked
into a buzzsaw you know that's a very
valuable pick in this draft that's
number six pick because of the depth of
the draft I think probably through the
first ten ten picks I think there's real
value I think they're going to be very
solid good NBA players down through the
first ten picks and and probably beyond
so so we value that pick and are
convinced that there's a player waiting
there to be drafted who can be a part of
the magic for next number of years and
be a contributor but have you just
trying to what you might be able to
reveal teams that are just trying to
give you players named players who we
are familiar with because they've been
in the NBA for awhile if not all-star
players being offered to you for that
pick or to try and involve you in a
three-way trade for somebody to be
acquired by another team and all these
deals that we're reading about Pat Oh
rich I would say all of the above you
know are being discussed and now we're
reading today about the Spurs and
LaMarcus Aldridge that suddenly the
Spurs would like to get into the top ten
so it's going to be very very
interesting right up until the start of
the draft and on into the draft that I
think they're going to be moves made
there tonight it's we've already had
probably the busiest preacher
after that I can remember maybe ever you
know some major deals have gone on here
that's that's highly unusual so I I
think we're in for a lot of excitement
tonight rich why is it do you think okay
well I think teams are doing desperate
to get better uh uh you know the
pressure to win is always always has
been great rich but it's probably
greater than ever now and I think the
reason is very simple the NBA has grown
to the point that it's a huge industry
owners are now dealing with you know
almost billion-dollar entities here they
want results they want them now and I
think that you guys that are running
ball clubs now realize that they've got
to do some radical stuff to try and get
better to try and catch the Warriors and
try and make inroads
it's a Cleveland and that's hard to do
but you you've got to do something
that's not normal necessary normal
normal business and so there I think
that's one of the reasons the prime
reason we're seeing a lot of activity
here a lot of kind of off-the-wall stuff
so what would you say Pat Williams is
more valuable in the current NBA a a top
seven or eight pick in this year's draft
or a name all-star player who is on the
verge of free agency who could join your
team it seems that we're seeing deals be
rejected by teams to try and hold on to
a draft choice and it's it's kind of
surprising or rich that whole thing of
free agency is scary you may get a
player for one year and then you may not
have him after one year so that has to
be counterbalanced by the fact that
you're going to get a draft pick used to
be with you guaranteed for X number of
years in the next number of years beyond
that so you better be awfully careful in
that whole free agency world because if
you're not if you give you miss your
calling or if you love it
you know you're going to be sent back
for a long long time and that's the
pressure
on all of these these guys around the
league you know who are making these
decisions on behalf of their owners
you know there's tremendous pressure on
them and to make the good call and
that's why tonight it's going to be so
interesting when we tee it up at 7:00
o'clock to see exactly how it unfolds
Pat Williams senior vice president to
the Orlando Magic been involved with the
NBA since the late 60s joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show so you have been
there and done that Pat if a player on
another team misses an exit interview
would that cause you to call that team
to see if that players available in a
trade well it seems to have stirred a
lot of calling into New York that's for
sure
it certainly would be a signal that
something is amiss and we're beginning
to find out now rich that something is
amiss there so I see Phil Jackson is
going public you know he's had a press
conference and talked openly about
what's going on so keep your eyes on New
York tonight you know there's going to
be could be some some real action there
how how often has a player missed an
exit interview and organizations that
you've been involved in ah probably
never omit maybe maybe here there you
know I don't remember I'm trying to
think back I I couldn't really tell you
one it's a pretty big deal a pretty big
deal you know next an interview is
designed to discuss with each player
their feelings and what they think what
their thoughts are about the year that's
just completed what their offseason
plans are here's what we here's what
we'd like you to work on son you know
here are some things that this offseason
you know you could be part of it cetera
and KP just selected to walk away from
all that it's not a good sign not not a
good signal so let me ask you one last
thing on that then Pat would you
consider it
an ex communicable defense
for you with a player regardless of age
and talent no no you could you can't do
that I I thought I thought Phil
Jackson's comments today we're
interesting he said if we got two
starters and maybe beyond you know we'd
consider it well I don't know how many
teams of this league rich can give up
two starters I'm not sure many so that's
why if I were a betting man you know I I
think kpov back there in the hall Pat
Williams senior VP of the Orlando Magic
joining me here on the show you drafted
Shaq into this league if he was
available on this draft would he be
would he be first overall surefire first
overall pick even in this day and age
where everybody's shooting threes and
it's a wide-open game pack Bob listen
rich if we got another crack at taking
Shaq first believe me we do it we do it
we do it every year for the next 20
years we know we have our center
position nailed down for at least a
decade and we know that we have our
building full every night and we know
that we have a very entertaining product
and we know it would be fun to come to
the games and yeah yeah it would be Shaq
and then the rest of the pack you know
it would be far beyond far behind well I
guess you know where I was going with
that though is this it just seems it's a
different game like the game has
completely changed we had Chris Webber
on during the finals pointing out about
Durant's worthiness that saying that the
Ben Wallace's of the league don't exist
anymore because you need someone to do
more than just rebound or shoot from
further back from five feet from the rim
he essentially said that I'm wondering
what you think well the game hasn't
really changed a lot since dr. Naismith
wrote and wrote the rules out in 1891
rich and that is you got to put the ball
either in a peach basket
or or in a connect yes somehow or other
you got to get get into that sir comfort
yes sir cumference I mean that's the aim
so that's why we're all looking for
shooters more importantly we're all
looking for makers we got a lot of
shooters but we want makers and that
that's always going to be the case and
and and and it's a real skill rich let's
I'm in amaizing find shooter makers
shooters you know they don't they don't
come out of college or high school or
you know all gifted with that some of
them get better when they get into the
league but I think it's a real just like
hitting a baseball or you know any other
great skill in sports shooting a
basketball consistently under great
pressure with a defender up in your face
you know you know putting his hand right
in front of your eyes and you still make
them that is a talent and we all want
that kind of talent we're looking for
them last one for you pat your
experience sixth sense about these sorts
of things do you think a trade happens
before you pick tonight in the draft oh
one through five yes sir no no no I
think I think we had that big one
affiliate Philly Boston was big enough
rich I mean I know you guys love to chew
under stuff yeah
well just wondering of it let me tell
you something sir I i GM the 76ers for
12 years never made a call to Boston on
any front I mean we were we were we were
bitter rivals can you can you picture me
calling red red Auerbach's to discuss a
trade red this is Pacific where this is
partly understand here I mean I got a
great idea what do you say Chris what
are you Crypt ember what do you want
what it would I don't bother
what is he you oh my goodness yeah I
know more call Red Auerbach we never
made a trade never talked to each other
yeah and so and so for the
- guys Bryan Colangelo and danny ainge
to work out this tray this flip-flop
absolutely unprecedented worthy of a
column by the great Bob Ryan that's what
I'm waiting to see I'm waiting to see
Bob Ryan do a column on this well amidst
amidst the madness yesterday Pat just
seeing the reports that the Celtics were
reaching out for porzingis and i just
thought to myself that i mean it
the knicks should just tell the celtics
to lose their number like why would they
even have their number you know that
that one was surprising to me to just
even heroes
well Danny Ainge is doing things here
use and that are unprecedented in that
in that division because of the intense
rivalries in the dislike for each other
now granted Philly and Boston have not
been rivals for a while I mean they but
but that that rivalry lies dormant and
when whenever it sparks up again
believe me the embers will turn into a
raging inferno Elian bosses believe me
great jet and you know now now can you
imagine that Knicks in Boston
nothing like draft night rich it's like
it's it's Christmas and New Year's and
fourth of July all rolled into one
a great fund and we all get to take it
in tonight's starting at 7:00 it should
be a great night enjoy Pat thanks for
calling and always enjoy our chats all
the best rich same year Pat Williams
Orlando Magic senior VP so Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches